[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal
wir kennen das aus der Vergangenheit
solche Auftritte bedeuten die Lage ist
ernst
wir sagen den SparerInnen und Sparern
dass ihre Einlagen sicher sind auch
dafür steht die Bundesregierung ein
is ready to do whatever it takes to
preserve the Europe
Bazooka mit der wir das Notwendige tun
und was wir dann noch an kleinen Waffen
brauchen das gucken wir später ganz
große Worte und ganz große Summen es war
der Versuch schon allein mit einem
psychologisch wichtigen Paukenschlag die
Situation zu beruhigen
guten Abend ihnen allen heute ist wieder
so ein Tag bis zu 200 Milliarden Euro
die hohen Energiepreise in den Griff
bekommen indem sie mit Steuergeld
gebremst werden das hat die Regierung
heute angekündigt die gasumlage ist tot
es lebe der sogenannte wirtschaftliche
Abwehrschirm wieder im Detail
funktionieren soll ist noch offen heute
ging es der Koalition um ein Signal ich
spreche dazu nachher mit dem
Bundeskanzler wir beginnen unsere
Berichterstattung heute Abend mit
Andreas Kühnast in Berlin
7 Minuten bevor der Bundesfinanzminister
die vielleicht folgenschwerste
Entscheidung seines bisherigen
regierungslebens verkündet steht
Christian Lindner vom Bundeskanzleramt
und wartet erst kam die ganze Koalition
nicht zueinander dann kam der Streit
zwischen Lindner und Harbeck dazu und
dann kommt Robert Habeck und dann gehen
die zwei heute versöhnten Minister
gemeinsam rein
und Scholz ist jetzt oben fragt Lindner
ja in seiner kemenade
es steht wo sonst Scholz sitzt ein
Monitor vor den Journalisten weil der
Kanzler noch in corona-karantäne ist
muss der Steinbrück Merkel dragimoment
des Olaf Scholz ohne Scholz stattfinden
der Hausherr wird von oben zugeschaltet
an eine Zeit vor Lindner und habe
erinnern an die corona-hilfen die die
groko damals den Wumms nannte man kann
sagen dass es hier ein Doppelpunkt es
soll dazu beitragen dass jetzt schnell
zügig und für alle schnell feststellbar
die Preise sinken für Energie so dass
sich niemand Sorgen machen muss wenn er
an den Herbst und den Winter denkt wenn
er an Weihnachten denkt und dann das
nächste Jahr und dann die Rechnung die
Gesamtrechnung für den Finanzminister
beläuft sich auf 200 Milliarden Euro
Lindners bisher folgenschwerste
Entscheidung aus dem gigantischen hilfs-
und Rettungspaket soll die
strompreisbremse bezahlt werden eine
gaspreisbremse sowie direkte Hilfen für
Gasanbieter und betroffene Unternehmen
die Mehrwertsteuersenkung für Gas soll
auch für Fernwärme gelten weil dieser
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfonds über
Kredite gefüllt wird kann Lindner neue
Schulden machen ohne die Schuldenbremse
zu lösen Deutschland zeigt hier seine
wirtschaftliche Schlagkraft in einem
energiekrieg die gasumlage von
Wirtschaftsminister Harbeck ist vom
Tisch trotzdem sollen Strom und Gas
gespart werden um den energiekrieg nicht
zu verlieren für eine Grundmenge an
Strom und vielleicht auch Gas will die
Regierung den Preis künstlich drastisch
senken wer aber mehr verbraucht soll
mehr bezahlen den dann womöglich sehr
hohen Marktpreis
die Speicher sind voll aber wir sehen
auch dass die verbreche gerade im
privaten Bereich noch nicht in dem Maße
runtergehen wie es eigentlich notwendig
wäre deswegen bei aller Bereitschaft des
viel Geld in die Hand zu nehmen und die
Preise abzufedern die Notwendigkeit
Energie einzusparen bleibt unvermindert
bestehen im achten Stock in der 30
Quadratmeter Dienstwohnung sitzt Olaf
Scholz seine Quarantäne ab der Kanzler
kann nur per Video für sein 200
Milliarden Paket werden und kann nur
hoffen dass es wirkt
ja Abwehrschirm der Regierung ist das
eine dieser Tag bringt aber eben auch
neue Prognosen wie sehr die deutsche
Wirtschaft einbrechen könnte
längerfristige Wohlstandsverluste ist
ein Begriff der dabei aufhorchen lässt
vom Ende des deutschen Erfolgsmodells in
der Wirtschaft sprechen andere David
Gebhard hat die Details dazu
heute morgen halb zehn in Deutschland
Döbeln wie überall im Land in Geschäften
Einkaufspassagen und kleinen Läden
wächst die Sorge dass der Wohlstand
schrumpft und damit die Chance selbst
wirtschaftlich irgendwie zu überleben
wenn man immer so hört diese Firma ist
schon insolvent und wird es was passiert
haben wir halt Angst davor dass viele
Leute in die Arbeitslosigkeit rutschen
mit 6,8 fahren Energiepreisen können die
unser Unternehmen nächstes Jahr nicht
weiterführen man Sport an jeder Ecke wo
man sparen kann also wo Sport mal das
ist
Friseur Kosmetik Nägel
Existenzängste Corona Kater in den
Knochen jetzt explodierende
Energiepreise die enorme Inflation
während die ampelmänner heute ihren
sogenannten Abwehrschirm verkünden
platzt eine Eilmeldung die Inflation in
Deutschland steigt auf 10% höchster Wert
seit 70 Jahren der Finanzminister will
mit dem sogenannten Abwehrschirm auch
die Inflation bekämpfen doch die
Subvention der Gaspreise die
gaspreisbremse glaubt mancher könnte die
Inflation sogar befeuern
es wird dadurch zusätzliche Kaufkraft in
die Breite der Bevölkerung getragen und
dadurch facht man dann die Inflation an
anderer Stelle wieder an das bedeutet
dann besonders für die unteren
Einkommensgruppen dass die Lebenshaltung
wieder teurer wird und dass wir den
gerade für diese Gruppe der man ja
besonders helfen will ein Bärendienst
und so bleibt Skepsis bei
Wirtschaftsexperten die am Vormittag mit
ihrer Herbstprognose ein düsteres Bild
gezeichnet hatten für nächstes Jahr
sehen Sie einen Rückgang der
Wirtschaftsleistung um 0,4 Prozent
voraus Rezession ein Wirtschaftssystem
das auf Wachstum setzt müsste das
Schrumpfen verdauen den
Wohlstandsverlust ich hoffe dass die
Ausgestaltung so ist dass es
funktioniert die Rezession die sich ja
jetzt schon klar abzeichnet wird massiv
verstärkt wenn wir hier keine
Unterstützung erfahren die
Opposition kritisiert das später handeln
und das Instrument für Sie die
Finanzierung des sogenannten
abwehrschirms ein Taschenspieler Trick
formal setzt man die Schuldenbremse
nicht aus aber man schafft eben
Sondervermögen das heißt
Schattenhaushalte die mit dem man dann
neue Schulden aufnimmt und die abseits
des Haushaltes stehen also es ist eine
Trickserei weil Sonderschulen in drei
stelliger Milliarden Höhe aufgenommen
werden aber die halt anders genannt
werden die entscheidende Frage ist wofür
wird das Geld eigentlich verwendet
es kommen die Worte gaspreisbremse und
strompreisbremse in dem Papier vor
beide mal bleibt völlig offen wie diese
gaspreisbremse und die strompreisbremse
denn gestaltet werden sollen eine
Expertengruppe soll nun die Details
erarbeiten und Anreize zum Energiesparen
denn die Knappheit des Gutes Gas bleibt
genau wie offene Fragen an den Kanzler
der Bundeskanzler ist bei uns direkt aus
seiner Wohnung im Kanzleramt wo er wegen
einer corona-infektion ist ich hoffe
dass es ihnen gut geht und sie auf dem
Weg der Besserung sind auf jeden Fall
danke dass Sie bei uns sind und guten
Abend Olaf Scholz
guten Abend es geht mir gut ich wurde
auch schon heute morgen negativ getestet
insofern hoffe ich dass die Quarantäne
bald zu Ende gehen kann okay prima das
sind gute Zeiten reden wir über das was
heute passiert ist das sollte ja jetzt
ein auch ein psychologisches Zeichen
sein 200 Milliarden seht her wir haben
Wirtschaftskraft und Geld und
gleichzeitig wissen wir Bürger alle wenn
die Politik so ein Zeichen setzt dann
ist die Lage meist schlimmer als gedacht
und wir erfahren das gerne erst
hinterher sind wir in so einer Situation
aktuell in Deutschland
nein wir haben eine sehr sehr
herausfordernde Situation aber haben uns
sehr früh gekümmert um die Sicherheit
der Energieversorgung in Deutschland zu
gewährleisten mit weitreichenden
Entscheidungen zum Beispiel dass die
Speicher voll sind über 90 Prozent ganz
anders als vor einem Jahr zum Beispiel
indem wir dafür gesorgt haben dass
Kohlekraftwerke wieder laufen und noch
nicht mehr vom Netz gehen so dass Strom
mit Kohle und nicht mit Gas produziert
wird das gleiche gilt für die
Möglichkeit das auch noch im Winter im
Januar Februar März April die
Atomkraftwerke im Süden weiterlaufen
können wir ermöglichen den Unternehmen
dass sie auf andere Weise ihre Energie
nutzen als mit Gas und wir bauen
Terminals an den norddeutschen Küsten
und Flüssiggas bald importieren zu
können und nutzen die der
westeuropäischen Häfen wir sind also
vorbereitet aber die Preise sind zu hoch
und die müssen runter und darum geht es
angesichts der Tatsache dass wir nun
sicher ist dass Russland wohl kein Gast
mehr liefern wird ob absehbare Zeit und
deshalb haben wir schon die
strompreisbremse auf den Weg gebracht an
deren Umsetzung wird arbeiten und haben
noch eine gaspreisbremse für Bürgern und
Bürger und für die Unternehmen damit das
auch tatsächlich wirkt damit die
Menschen wissen womit sie planen und
womit Sie rechnen können muss man
natürlich verstehen wie diese
gaspreisbremse dann konkret ausgestaltet
sein soll wie sie funktionieren soll
also ist das so dass ich quasi für einen
Großteil meines Verbrauchs den Preis aus
dem letzten Jahr dann bezahle
die ganz konkrete Ausgestaltung werden
wir festlegen sobald wir den Vorschlag
des Expertengremiums haben dass wir
schon vor einiger Zeit eingesetzt haben
und das zu Tagen begonnen hat wir werden
Mitte Oktober vielleicht sogar etwas
früher den Vorschlag haben und dann
sofort das alles umsetzen was da
herauskommt aber da geht es schon darum
dass die Preise wieder runtergehen und
zwar so dass man als Rentnerin als
arbeitnehmerehepaar als Familie auf dem
Lande sich die Preise wieder leisten
kann und das gilt natürlich auch für die
Handwerksbetriebe für die großen
Unternehmen damit die Arbeitsplätze
erhalten bleiben jetzt haben wir ja
Bundeskanzler gerade bei der gasumlage
allerdings gemerkt dass der Teufel dann
am Ende doch im Detail steckt und zwar
bei der konkreten Ausgestaltung also
wird es denn dann so sein dass wir alle
denselben Gaspreis zu zahlen haben oder
wie soll das aussehen
die haben mir eben schon gehört dass wir
eine Kommission eingesetzt hat die das
genau und wirksam festlegen wird und uns
Vorschläge machen wird die wir dann
umsetzen können aber es geht eben um
eine massive Senkung des Gaspreises oder
des wärmepreises der auf Gas beruht den
man zu zahlen hat und das Unternehmen
das einem Fernwärme liefert zum Beispiel
und deshalb sind das sehr sehr
weitreichende Mittel die wir bereits
stellen damit wir lange durchhalten
können und damit die Bürgern und Bürger
sicher sein können dass so lange durch
Knappheit die Preise zu hoch sind wie
sie auch runter subventionieren und
gleichzeitig kümmern wir uns natürlich
darum dass das nicht dabei bleibt denn
die Gaspreise in der Welt müssen wieder
runtergehen wir haben viele Verträge mit
vielen Ländern bereits neu abgeschlossen
und kommen noch da kommen noch weitere
denn das ist das Ziel am Ende sollen die
Preise wieder ein normales Niveau
erreichen und nicht für die Bürgerinnen
und Bürger und für die Unternehmen
dadurch
wieder normal werden bei der Staat mit
viel Geld das runtersubventionieren
aktuell ist es allerdings so dass der
Gasverbrauch der Haushalte hat die
Bundesnetzagentur heute gerade gesagt
wieder viel zu stark hoch geht ist das
jetzt was sie heute senden nicht auch
ein Signal Leute wir fangen alles auf
ihr müsst euch also kaum einschränken
auch ein Zeichen an energieintensive
Branchen zum Beispiel das ist im Grunde
genommen so weitergehen kann sie haben
heute gesagt der Bundeskanzler niemand
muss sich Sorgen machen
ich glaube das ist etwas zynisch wäre
sich jetzt zu überlegen wie man mit
hohen Preisen dafür sorgt dass es dazu
führt dass jemand etwas tut was er nicht
richtig findet natürlich wollen wir
weiter dafür sorgen dass eingespart wird
und wir haben ja dazu auch alle
Möglichkeiten und Mittel aber was wir
nicht akzeptieren können ist dass jemand
seine
Stromrechnung kriegt seine Heizung nicht
weiß wie er das alles bezahlen soll und
ganz verzweifelt vor diesem Brief
sitzen bleibt und das wollen wir ändern
indem wir jetzt so viel Geld einsetzen
für dieses Jahr für das nächste Jahr und
auch wenn es nötig ist im Jahr 2024
damit man nach vorne gucken kann und das
ist das was wir jetzt schaffen das ist
eine akute Krise da muss man akut
Handeln unsere langfristige Politik ist
ja sowieso darauf ausgerichtet aus der
Nutzung fossiler Ressourcen auszusteigen
mit riesigem Schwung waren wir jetzt die
erneuerbaren Energien aus und haben dazu
sogar noch viele neue Entscheidungen
getroffen damit das voran geht der
Windkraft auf hoher See an Land mit der
solaren
gie es ist sehr viel Geld ihr
Wirtschaftsminister hat heute gesagt 200
Milliarden die standen vor ein paar
Wochen noch nicht zur Verfügung
jetzt ist das Geld ja nicht plötzlich
irgendwo aufgetaucht das macht immerhin
fast den halben Gesamthaushalt der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland aus das ist
mittlerweile ein gewaltiger Schuldenberg
der sich da auftürmt es gibt ja auch
noch andere Ausgaben knapp 100
Milliarden für die anderen
entlastungspakete 100 Milliarden für die
Bundeswehr wir riskant ist es denn mit
so vielen Schattenhaushalten zu
operieren das sind keine
Schattenhaushalte es ist alles sehr
überschaubar
wir sind schon Haushalte die natürlich
nicht im offiziellen Haushalt auftauchen
sondern als Sondervermögen sprich
sonderschulden oder mit besonderen Fonds
gestemmt werden die am Ende auch
schuldiglich im Schatten denn sie
sprechen ja über die die sind ja
offenbar nicht verborgen geblieben und
wir haben sie sogar heute stolz
präsentiert diesen ein das gilt übrigens
auch für das Sondervermögen für die
Bundeswehr das ist ja auch auf mehrere
Jahre gerichtet genauso wie es hier um
Mittel geht die wir einsetzen wollen in
diesem Jahr im nächsten und dem
übernächsten Jahr aber klar die
Entlastung für die Bürger und Bürger
muss angesichts der Tatsache dass da ein
Kriegs stattfindet den Russland gegen
die Ukraine begonnen hat der mit größter
Brutalität von Russland vorangetrieben
wird und dass der Krieg Auswirkung hat
auf uns muss es so sein dass wir jetzt
auch alle Kraft zeigen die wir haben und
da wird immer gut gewerkschaftet haben
da wir im Verhältnis zu den anderen G7
Staaten die geringste Schuldenquote
haben können wir das machen was wir in
solchen Situationen schon öfter gemacht
haben in der Krisensituation Kredite
aufnehmen aber dafür zu sorgen dass wir
dann wenn es wieder ordentlich läuft
dafür alles dazu beitragen dass unser
Schuldenstand wieder sinkt das ist uns
schon mal gelungen das ist auch jetzt
etwas was uns gelingen würde wenn nicht
die neue Krise dabei wäre aber nach Ende
dieser Krise wird das auch wieder
gelingen auch deshalb übrigens weil wir
die Wirtschaftskraft unseres Landes
erhalten und weil wir uns genau darauf
konzentrieren diese Maßnahmen auf das
auszurichten wor es mir geht nämlich
dafür zu sorgen dass die Energiepreise
runtergehen damit die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger und die Unternehmen damit
zurechtkommen sie haben gerade den Krieg
angesprochen Entspannung ist ja wirklich
in keiner Weise in Sicht was war ihr
erster Gedanke als sie gehört haben von
diesen großen Lex in den nordstream
Pipelines das ist bedrückend aber
insofern etwas was mich
wiederum auch nicht wundert weil ich
sehr früh davon ausgegangen war das ist
passieren wird dass der Transport von
Gast durch diese Pipelines von Russland
beendet wird und das ist ja schon längst
passiert das Leck oder die verschiedenen
Zerstörung die da gemacht worden sind
und verursacht worden sind sind ja
an Pipelines verübt worden die gar nicht
mehr zu unserer gastversorgung beitragen
in der gegenwärtigen Situation trotzdem
ist das etwas Bedrückendes und auch ein
Zeichen dafür dass wir uns wirklich in
einer sehr ernsten Lage befinden und
deshalb das Richtige tun müssen das
Richtige ist entschlossen zu handeln
mutig zu handeln aber auch immer
umsichtig
von einem energiekrieg war heute
häufiger die Rede ein echter Krieg läuft
ja auch morgen will Präsident Putin die
besetzten Gebiete offiziell sich
einverleiben Russland einverleiben er
würde dann alles in Zukunft als ein
Angriff auf Russland sehen zumindest aus
seiner Sicht was heißt denn das jetzt
für die Zukunft des Krieges und für
unsere Reaktion
wir werden diese annektionen nicht
akzeptieren dass werden auch viele
andere nicht tun in der ganzen Welt
sogar diejenigen die ein bisschen ab der
Seite immer zugeschaut haben wie der
Krieg sich weiterentwickelt werden diese
Maßnahmen nicht akzeptieren da hat Putin
sich und sein Land weiter isoliert
und wie reagieren Sie wenn es soweit
kommen sollte was tatsächlich jetzt bei
der NATO und in Sicherheitskreisen ja
auch zunehmend nicht mehr ausgeschlossen
wird als Szenario dass man sich
eigentlich gar nicht vorstellen möchte
nämlich das Putin seine Drohung
tatsächlich wahr machen könnte und
Nuklearwaffen einsetzt muss man sich auf
sowas aktuell vorbereiten aus ihrer
Sicht
wir haben immer ganz klar Richtung
Russland gesagt solche Waffen dürfen
nicht eingesetzt werden als es am Anfang
des Krieges eine heftige Diskussion in
Russland gab über biologisch und
chemische Waffen die angeblich in der
Ukraine sich befänden was völlig unwahr
war haben wir klar gesagt das darf kein
Vorwand sein um jetzt selber solche
einzusetzen was es bleiben und das
gleiche gilt jetzt auch der
amerikanische Präsident hat genauso wie
ich und viele andere gesagt das sind
Waffen die nicht eingesetzt werden
dürfen
der Bundeskanzler im heute journal ich
danke Ihnen ganz herzlich für das
Gespräch herr Scholz
schönen Dank
und das Gespräch mit der Bundeskanzlerin
aus Termin Gründen am Nachmittag
aufgezeichnet nachher im heute-journal
Update Fragen von Wulf schmiese an die
Chefin der Kommission die jetzt die
konkreten Details dieser gaspreisbremse
klären muss
ich habe ja gerade schon mit dem
Bundeskanzler darüber geredet die
Situation die uns all das eingebrockt
hat ist weiter bedrohlich der russische
Präsident will morgen die besetzten
ukrainischen Gebiete seinem Land
offiziell einverleiben Russland droht
weiter und verholen auch mit nuklear
Schlägen Wladimir Putin sagt heute
unsere Gegner sind bereit Revolutionen
zur provozieren und dann gibt es
weiterhin die große Sorge dass die
Anschläge auf zwei Gaspipelines in der
Ostsee nicht die letzten gewesen sind
Florian neuhahn und Gunnar Krüger mit
mehr dazu
Dritter Tag viertes Leck und weiter 0
Durchblick in der Ostsee klar ist nur
was hier in wenigen Tagen aus den
Pipelines strömt ist so klimaschädlich
wie ein Prozent des deutschen
CO2-Ausstoßes eines ganzen Jahres es ist
eine Katastrophe für die Umwelt und Zeit
der Spekulationen über den Urheber danke
USA schrieb ein ehemaliger polnischer
Außenminister in einem mittlerweile
gelöschten Tweet
das russische Staatsfernsehen und
die Ukraine eindeutig der Gewinner denn
nun nimmt die Bedeutung ihrer Pipeline
für Europa stark zu
und Putin Sprecher sagt einen Satz den
so auch der Westen formuliert so eine
Terror Tat ist schwer vorstellbar ohne
die Verwicklung eines Staates
doch viele im Westen denken dabei an den
russischen Staat CNN zitiert
Geheimdienste russische Kriegsschiffe
hielten sich angeblich kurz vor den
Explosionen in der Nähe auf das alles
zwingt die NATO sich zu positionieren
hier tagt der nordatlantikrat 30
alliierte plus Schweden und Finnland
erklären alles deute darauf hin dass die
lex Ergebnis gezielter rücksichts- und
verantwortungsloser Sabotageakte sein
man würde auf jeden vorsätzlichen
Angriff auf die kritische Infrastruktur
der Verbündeten geschlossen und
entschieden reagieren
die Reaktion das ist nicht Artikel 5 das
schärfste Schwert der NATO die
Beistandspflicht aber wenn sie Beweise
für Russlands Schuld findet dann hätte
die nato-optionen sagt ein ehemaliger
nato-stratege the freshfink will NATO
jede Infrastruktur so gut wie möglich
schützen zweitens hoffe ich dass sie
über eine Form der Seeblockade nachdenkt
gegen russische Handelsschiffe in der
Ostsee
derweil bauen sie in Moskau auf für eine
Feier auf dem Roten Platz die besetzten
Gebiete und Russland für immer vereint
steht da es wäre Putins nächste
Eskalation
und das würde natürlich unter Umständen
bedeuten dass wenn die Ukraine den Krieg
fortführt dass sie dann nach russischer
Lesart russisches Territorium angreifen
würde verletzen würde und theoretisch
würde dann die nukleare Doktrin
Russlands greifen nach dieser Doktrin
könnte Putin theoretisch Atomwaffen
gegen die Ukraine einsetzen Frage ist ob
der Westen sich von Moskaus Drohung
beeindrucken lässt
ja live nach Moskau zu Christian sem
welche Hinweise gibt es denn das
Präsident Putin dann quasi eine ganz
neue Phase des Krieges beginnt in dem er
Kämpfe in diesen Regionen als eine Art
Verteidigung Russlands verkaufen könnte
ja putin wird morgen die Annexion dieser
vier Gebiete die wird er hier als großen
Erfolg verkaufen das wird auch
entsprechend gefeiert das ist auf jeden
Fall der Plan für morgen und dann wird
ja immer wieder darauf hingewiesen wie
sehr sich die rechtliche Situation in
diesem Gebieten eben durch diesen
Anschluss verändern würde und Russland
sagt ganz klar wenn es Angriff auf
dieses Gebiet gibt dann sei die terriale
Integrität des Landes verletzt man sei
bereit mit allen Waffen zurückgeschlagen
und lässt da die Atomwaffen auch nicht
aus und man weiß dass man eben mit
dieser Angst immer wieder spielen kann
argumentiert ja auch dass man sich
gleichsam vom Westen von den Atomwaffen
bedroht fühle wie weit Putin zum Schluss
geht ja das weiß zum Schluss nur er
wir haben es jetzt mehrfach schon gesagt
Christian morgen ist der Tag an dem
diese besetzten Gebiete in der Ukraine
von Russland annektiert werden sollen
wie hat man sich denn das ganz konkret
vorzustellen was ist da geplant
also in Moskau das soll morgen groß und
pompös sein Wladimir Putin wird im
georgsaal ganz feierlich im Kreml wird
er die entsprechenden Dokumente
unterzeichnen die dann den offiziellen
Beitritt dieser vier Gebiete zur
Russischen Föderation besiegeln sollen
draußen auf dem Roten Platz wir haben
das heute schon gesehen wird eine große
Bühne aufgebaut der Platz soll voll sein
da wird es dann ein Rockkonzert geben
das soll also entsprechend gefeiert
werden ob Putin dann da auf dieser Bühne
auch noch auftritt wie 2014 bei der Krim
Annexion das ist noch nicht klar ob das
jetzt die Russen insgesamt so
elektrisiert das ist doch eher fraglich
ich glaube sie beschäftigen sich im
Moment mit einer ganz anderen Frage
viele haben doch die sorgen dass Putin
morgen den Tag nutzen wird um noch ganz
andere Dinge zu verkünden also
beispielsweise das Kriegsrecht oder eine
gesamte mobil machen viele haben auch
Angst dass Putin morgen sagen könnte
dass die Grenzen geschlossen werden für
alle Wehrpflichtigen und das hat auch
noch mal diesen Exodus den wir in den
letzten Tagen so massiv gesehen haben an
den russischen Außengrenzen das hat
diesen Exodus auch noch mal extrem
befeuert also einen Tag auf den wir alle
gespannt gucken werden Christian Sems
ZDF Moskau vielen Dank und bis morgen
also während Wladimir Putin mit der Teil
Mobilmachung für die Armee und den Krieg
sein Land erschüttert Antworten die
Russen mit einer Mobilmachung der ganz
anderen Art wir haben es gerade schon
kurz gehört an Russlands Grenzen sind
aber tausende unterwegs um rauszukommen
der Einberufung zu entgehen nach
Finnland Kasachstan Georgien wie lange
das überhaupt noch geht ist fraglich
Christian sem berichtet von der russisch
georgischen Grenze
Romans Roller will nicht mehr kurz
hinter der georgischen Grenze streiken
die Reifen aber Mission erfüllt vorbei
an den kilometerlangen Staus ein Roller
als Fluchthelfer jetzt ist der
22-Jährige Produktdesigner aus dem
russischen nigninow gerod erstmal nach
Tiflis in die georgische Hauptstadt und
fühlt sich sicher Roman erinnert sich an
dem Moment letzte Woche als Putin die
teilmobilisierung verkündete und ihm
schlagartig klar wurde dass er jetzt
schnell weg muss aus Russland
ich machte gerade meine Aufgaben für den
Englischkurs als ich die Übertragung sah
fingen meine Hände an zu zittern ich
habe sofort begriffen dass mein
Stiefvater unter die erste Welle der
Mobilmachung fallen würde er zeigte dass
meiner Mutter es war der Horror ich saß
da meine Hände zitterten und die Tränen
flossen
Putins Ankündigung hat in fast jeder
Familie in Russland Panik ausgelöst die
Russen plötzlich rausgerissen aus ihrer
Passivität zu Putins sogenannter
spezialoperation in der Ukraine ob mit
dem Roller zu Fuß mit dem Fahrrad oder
mit dem Auto jetzt kommen rund 10.000
Russen jeden Tag über den Grenzpunkt in
vernillas nach Georgien vor allem junge
und die die sich die Flucht überhaupt
leisten können ein Exodus
wir wollten keine Zeit mehr verlieren
wegen der Information oder
Desinformation dass die Grenze zumacht
wir haben das Auto stehen lassen und
haben uns auf den Weg gemacht
wir sind nicht einverstanden mit der
eingeschlagenen Politik in unserem Land
und wollen nicht in einen Krieg
reingezogen werden mit dem wir nicht
einverstanden sind wir wollen keine
Opfer und wollen auch selbst nicht Opfer
dieses Krieges werden
georgien hat seit dem russischen
Einmarsch 2008 ein sehr angespanntes
Verhältnis zum Nachbarn und so gibt es
Proteste von Georgien und Ukrainern dass
die georgische Regierung die Russen
einfach so ins Land lässt
wir wissen nicht wer sie sind vielleicht
sind es russische Agenten oder
russisches Militär auch in dieser Bar
ein tiefles wollen Sie wissen mit wem
Sie hier zusammen feiern wer rein will
muss sich von Putin distanzieren und
folgendem Satz zustimmen ich habe Putin
nicht gewählt er ist ein Diktator ich
verurteile die russische Aggression in
der Ukraine
große Pläne hat von den geflüchteten
Russen keiner im Moment dominieren die
Fragezeichen
Roman will erstmal ein paar Monate
bleiben dann mal sehen auch viele seiner
gut ausgebildeten Kollegen sind schon
weg aus Russland
es sind sehr viele vor allem Kollegen
hauptsächlich IT-Spezialisten drei
Kollegen sind bereits nach Istanbul
geflogen ein anderer ist schon hier
angekommen sechs Stunden nach mir dann
noch zwei weitere Freunde
wladimir Putin hat mit seiner
angekündigten Teil Mobilisierung
tatsächlich dafür gesorgt dass die
Menschen sich in Bewegung setzen aber
nicht um für Russland zu kämpfen sondern
um vor der Einberufung zu flüchten und
die angst steigt das Putin die Grenzen
bald dicht macht
so viele Russen die genau wissen wie
wenig ihrer Regierung zu trauen ist
ein ereignisreicher nachrichtentag heute
dessen andere Entwicklungen du jetzt im
Blick hast Hannah ja Christian nordkorea
hat laut Südkorea erneut ballistische
Raketen getestet zum dritten Mal
innerhalb weniger Tage und nur wenige
Stunden nach dem Besuch von
us-vizepräsidentin Harris in Südkorea
bei einem Treffen mit dem
südkoreanischen Präsidenten June
bekräftigte Harris dass die USA zur
Abschreckung Nordkoreas mit der gesamten
Bandbreite ihrer militärischen
Fähigkeiten an der Seite Südkoreas
stünde dieser Woche hatten die USA und
Südkorea eine gemeinsame marineübung vor
der koreanischen Halbinsel abgehalten
amnesty International fordert wegen der
Gewalt gegen Protestierende in Iran eine
internationale Untersuchung der UN die
Menschenrechtsorganisation erklärte sie
habe die Vorfälle dokumentiert und
berichtet von scharfer Munition Schlägen
und sexualisierter Gewalt die die
Sicherheitskräfte gegen demonstrierende
einsetzen die Situation in Iran war
heute außerdem Thema bei einer aktuellen
Stunde im Bundestag dabei forderte
bundesaußenministerin baerbock neue
EU-Sanktionen gegen Iran
gestorben
Rezessionsangst eine steigende
Inflationsrate und teure
entlastungsversprechen die aktuelle
Nachrichtenlage wird auch an den
Finanzmärkten ganz genau beobachtet
Frank Bethmann an der Frankfurter Börse
wie hat heute der deutsche Leitindex
darauf reagiert den Druck der schlechten
Nachrichten spürt man natürlich auch
hier kaum an einen Tag an dem dem Dax
nicht ein dicker Brocken serviert wird
so kommentierte es sinngemäß heute ein
Börsianer der DAX verliert heute über
200 Punkte und rutscht dabei unter die
Marke von 12.000 Zählern vor allem die
zehn Prozent Inflation und die Erwartung
dass die Teuerung sogar noch weiter auf
über 12 Prozent steigen könnte bereitet
den Märkten Sorge denn die Europäische
Zentralbank so viel scheint klar wird
die Leitzinsen weiter anheben die
Aussicht auf höhere Zinsen aber macht
die Kredite für Unternehmen teurer der
Kostendruck für die Betriebe nimmt
weiter zu das ganze droht die Konjunktur
abzuwürgen die Börse geht also erstmal
in Deckung
und ausgerechnet in diesen unruhigen
Zeiten hat Porsche heute sein
Börsendebüt gefeiert wie ist das
gelaufen gut wenngleich die anfänglichen
Kursgewinne nur von kurzer dauerwahn und
zum Handelsende die Porsche Aktie fast
unter ihren Ausgabepreis gerutscht wäre
am Morgen beinahe surreale Bilder mitten
in der Krise volles Parkett und
ausgelassene Stimmung die porsche-chefs
Leuten in brünstig fast 40 Sekunden lang
die neue Ära des Sportwagenherstellers
ein Porsche zurück an der Börse
eigenständiger nicht mehr eine von
vielen Marken im Verbund des VW-Konzerns
und doch weiterhin unter Kontrolle der
Konzernmutter und der inhaberfamilien
die weiterhin eine deutliche Mehrheit am
Sportwagenbauer halten vielen Dank Frank
für diese Einschätzung
in Stockholm wurde heute die preist
wurden heute die Preisträger des
sogenannten alternativen Nobelpreis
bekannt gegeben ausgezeichnet wurde
unter anderem die ukrainische
Menschenrechtlerin olexandra matt
wiechuk die rüstin dokumentiert
russische Kriegsverbrechen um eine
strafrechtliche Verfolgung der Täter zu
ermöglichen seit Kriegsbeginn sein über
19.000 Fälle aktenkundigt so matt wie
Schuck weitere Preisträger des right
lively Hood Awards kommen aus Somalia
Venezuela und Uganda
Hurrikan Ian hat in Florida für Schäden
von historischem Ausmaß gesorgt das
erklärte der Gouverneur des
US-Bundesstaats mit heftigen Winden
Starkregen und Sturmfluten traf ihren
gestern auf Land und sorgte für massive
Zerstörungen und Stromausfälle die Zahl
der Opfer ist noch unklar US-Präsident
beiden befürchtet hohe Todeszahlen die
Behörden warnen weiterhin vor
Überschwemmungen noch konnten die
Rettungskräfte nicht in alle Gebiete
vorrücken
schlimme Bilder aus einem sonnigen
Paradies damit ist das heute journal zu
Ende dieser wichtige Nachrichten
Donnerstag ist es noch nicht Krieg und
Krise ist Deutschland überfordert unter
diesem Motto diskutieren gleich bei der
Kollegin Maybrit Illner die Parteichefs
von FDP GRÜNEN und CDU miteinander und
wir alle hier sagen tschüss und wünschen
Ihnen jetzt noch einen angenehmen Abend
[Musik]
guten Abend darf ich vorstellen ein
kleines Zwischenhoch zieht morgen hier
von West nach Ost über uns hinweg am
Mittelmeer gibt es dagegen kräftige
Unwetter und hier kringelt sich schon
ein Sturmtief ein heute Nacht fällt
Regen zum einen hier in Südosten zum
anderen aber auch im Nordwesten
dazwischen aber lockern die Wolken auf
es bildet sich neuer Nebel und dann wird
es kalt dann sinken die Temperaturen auf
+3 bis -1 Grad dann gibt es also nicht
nur ganz vereinzelt Bodenfrost milder
bleiben die Nachttemperaturen am
Alpenrand und an den Küsten bei 8 bis 4
Grad die Höchsttemperaturen morgen
liegen zwischen 11 Grad am Alpenrand und
18 Grad am Niederrhein und das wird ein
freundlicher Freitag Sonne und Wolken
wechseln sich ab und dann freundlichsten
wird es hier wohl zwischen der
Ostseeküste und Berlin-Brandenburg
anders sieht das in Süddeutschland aus
da fällt vor allen Dingen am Vormittag
hier noch ein bisschen Regen am
Nachmittag kann sich dann auch im Allgäu
immer häufiger die Sonne zeigen und
jetzt schauen wir uns mal diese
Sturmtief genauer an nämlich schon in
der Nacht zu Samstag wird der Wind bei
uns zunehmen aber sie sehen die
kräftigsten Windböen die bleiben doch
hier über dem Atlantik jetzt schauen wir
uns den Samstag und den Sonntag genauer
an das wird ein windiges ein
regnerisches Wochenende bei Temperaturen
von 10 bis 19 Grad zum Tag der Deutschen
Einheit am 3 Oktober aber wird es von
Südwesten deutlich freundlicher und wie
sie hier am Wetter und temperaturtrend
für Freiburg im Breisgau sehen können
klettern die Temperaturen nächste Woche
nicht nur über 15 sondern vielleicht
sogar über 20 Grad guten Abend